[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic le champ électromagnétique
imaginons deux personnes dans le vide de
l'espace qui s'échangent d'une balle au
moment d'envoyer la balle
le premier individu va saint prime et
une certaine vitesse de recul car il
donne son énergie à la balle de même au
moment de la recevoir
l'autre personne va absorber le
mouvement de la balle est donc également
ressentir une vitesse de recul en
s'échangeant la balle les deux individus
ont accéléré ils étaient au départ
immobile ils sont maintenant en
mouvement ils s'éloignent l'un de
l'autre avec une certaine vitesse s'il
continue de s'échanger la balle leurs
vitesses respectives vont à chaque fois
augmenté et ils vont s'éloigner toujours
de plus en plus vite
tout se passe comme s'il subissait une
force qui les repousse l'action de la
balle peut être synthétisés par une
force de répulsion dans la nature à
l'échelle quantique
ce même phénomène est à l'oeuvre entre
certaines particules comme les électrons
qui sont sans cesse en train de
s'échanger des photons virtuel
un photon virtuel est une particule
issus des lois de la physique quantique
qui a le droit d'apparaître à partir de
rien à condition qu'elle disparaisse
suffisamment vite pour qu'il soit
absolument impossible de la détecter un
photon virtuel possède une certaine
énergie et sa durée de vie est d'autant
plus courte que son énergie est
importante
ainsi - un photon virtuel et énergétique
c'est-à-dire plus son énergie est faible
plus il pourra parcourir une grande
distance en s'échangeant des photons
virtuel les électrons ressentent une
répulsion une force qui les repousse un
peu comme le cas des deux personnes qui
s'échangeaient la balle
cette force est d'autant plus puissante
que les électrons sont rapprochés l'un
de l'autre
car les photons virtuel est alors moins
de distance à parcourir et peuvent ainsi
être plus énergétiques les électrons ne
sont pas les seuls particules interagir
de la sorte
beaucoup d'autres particules s'échangent
des photons virtuel et on appelle cette
tendance qu'ont certaines particules à
interagir leur charge électrique
l'électron possède une charge électrique
2 - 1 e e représente simplement l'unité
de base pour la charge électrique une
particule va avoir comme charge
électrique un multiple de cette brique
élémentaire
certains objets interagissent davantage
qu'un électron on peut imaginer un objet
qui en contient 2 et dont la charge
électrique serait alors de - 2 e
de plus certaines particules comme le
proton interagissent avec les photos
virtuelles de façon opposée
leur charge électrique est alors
positive la charge du proton est par
exemple de plus un e tout comme les
électrons de particules de charges
positives vont se repousser mais une
particule négative avec une particule
positives vont s'attirer ainsi les
charges de même signes se repoussent
tandis que les charges opposés
s'attirent pour prendre en compte toutes
ces interactions on introduit la notion
de champ électrique
pour ce faire on peut imaginer une sorte
de tissu imaginaire qui remplirait tout
l'espace
si on place un électron de charge
négative le chant va ce coloré en bleu
autour de lui al'inverse si on place un
breton de charges positives
le chant va ce coloré en rouge de façon
naturelle
les particules vont s'échapper des zones
qui possède la même couleur qu'elle une
particules neutres sans charge
électrique ne va rien ressentir elle va
se déplacer en ligne droite comme si de
rien n'était mais une charge électrique
positive comme un proton va être
repoussée par les zones rouges est
attiré par les zones bleues al'inverse
une charge négative est attiré par les
zones rouges est repoussé par les zones
bleues illustrons le champ électrique
avec plusieurs exemples
voilà le champ créée par deux électrons
on voit par exemple que la position
centrale entre les deux électrons est
une position d'équilibré
si on y place une particule celle-ci
resterait immobile un peu comme une
bille entre deux bosses voilà maintenant
le champ créé par un électron et un
proton on voit que les deux particules
satire le champ électrique forme une
sorte de pont de l'une vers l'autre
enfin en plaçant une chaîne d'électrons
d'un côté et une chaîne de protons de
l'autre on peut créer un champ
électrique uniforme
c'est à dire qu'une particule dans ce
champ ressentir est toujours la même
force
où qu'elle soit de cette façon on peut
par exemple mettre en mouvement les
électrons à l'intérieur d'un fil
électrique
c'est ce qu'on appelle un courant
électrique c'est alors qu'entre en jeu
une expérience troublante
imaginons un fil électrique composé
d'une très longue chaîne de protons et
électrons dans lequel s'écoule un
courant électrique
le courant électrique correspond
simplement un déplacement des électrons
le long du fil imaginons qu'on place un
objet à une certaine distance du fils
par exemple une pomme qui possède une
certaine charge électrique positive
d'après les interactions qu'on a vu
précédemment chaque protons dans l'oeuf
il repousse la pomme car leurs charges
sont toutes deux positive mais en même
temps chaque électrons attire la pomme
avec la même intensité
globalement quand on fait la somme de
toutes ses forces celles ci se compense
parfaitement et la pomme ne ressent au
total aucune force
effectivement quand on observe elle
reste bel et bien immobile mais on va
maintenant lui donner une vitesse de
déplacement vers la droite
étrangement on observe alors que la
pomme est progressivement repoussés par
le fil alors qu'elle ne ressent aucune
force électrique
tout se passe comme si une autre force
mystérieuse agissait en secret sur la
pomme la repoussant du fil
cette nouvelle force est un peu
particulière elle n'agit pas quand la
pomme est immobile mais seulement quand
elle est en mouvement
de plus cette force dépend de la
direction et de la vitesse à laquelle se
déplace la pomme on appelle cette force
étonnante qui apparaît lorsque décharge
électrique se déplace la force
magnétique pour comprendre l'origine de
cette force il va être nécessaire
d'étudier ce que nous enseigne la
relativité restreinte
pour commencer on va observer la
situation non pas d'un point de vue
extérieur mais plutôt telle qu'elle est
perçue par notre pomme
on va se placer dans son point de vue
par rapport au point de vue de la pomme
ce n'est pas elle qui se déplace vers la
droite mais le fils qui se déplace vers
la gauche
d'après la relativité restreinte plus un
objet se déplacent rapidement plus sa
longueur va être contractée dans le sens
du mouvement dans notre expérience les
protons dans le fil sont maintenant en
mouvement par rapport à la pomme il se
déplace vers la gauche ils vont ainsi
être contractée dans la longueur du fil
et tout se passe comme si les protons
s'était légèrement rapprocher les uns
des autres
al'inverse les électrons semble
maintenant se déplacer plus lentement
ils ont perdu un peu de vitesse car le
fils tout entier se déplace maintenant
vers la gauche ils sont donc légèrement
étiré par rapport au point de vue
précédent et tout se passe comme si les
électrons s'étaient éloignés les uns des
autres
globalement quand on fait la somme des
forces qui s'exercent sur la paume de
son point de vue celle ci ne se
compensent plus il y à davantage de
charge électrique positive des protons
dans le fil que de charges négatives et
par conséquent le fil en entier va
exercer une force répulsive sur la pomme
qui va progressivement l'an éloignés
en prenant en compte la relativité
restreinte
on s'aperçoit que le champ électrique
générée par une charge se déforme quand
celle ci se met en mouvement
ce phénomène entraîne l'apparition d'une
nouvelle force la force magnétique qui
n'est en fait qu'une simple force
électrique mais perçue selon un point de
vue différent
de façon analogue aux champs électriques
on peut résumer tous ces comportements
par un autre champ le champ magnétique
quand une charge électrique se déplace
elle crée autour d'elle un champ
magnétique qu'on peut représenter par
des flèches qui tourne autour de la
direction de son mouvement la force
magnétique est une conséquence de la
relativité restreinte et par conséquent
le comportement du champ magnétique est
plutôt étrange dans un champ magnétique
une particule immobile ne ressent aucune
force
par contre une particule en mouvement va
ressentir une force qui est d'autant
plus importante que la particule se
déplacent perpendiculairement à la
direction du champ magnétique
cette force va avoir tendance à faire
tourner les particules suivant des
trajectoires en hélice et encerclent
dont la taille dépend de leur masse de
leur vitesse de l'intensité du champ ou
encore de leurs charges électriques
bien qu'il est difficile à visualiser on
peut se donner une certaine intuition du
champ magnétique en imaginant
l'expérience suivante
on enroule un film sur lui même de sorte
à former une longue bobines et on
applique dans ce fil un courant
électrique en se déplaçant à l'intérieur
du fil chacun des électrons va créer
autour de lui un petit champ magnétique
globalement tous ces petits champs
magnétiques fonds s'additionner formant
au total un champ à grande échelle qui
forment une sorte de boucle sortant par
une extrémité de la bobine et rentrant
par l'autre extrémité de cette façon
notre bobine se comporte comme une sorte
d'aimant c'est-à-dire un objet qui
possède un pôle nord et un pôle sud
magnétique on appelle ce type d'objet un
électroaimant pour les aimants comme
pour les charges électriques l'épaule de
même type se repoussent tandis que les
pôles opposés s'attirent au centre de la
bobine le champ magnétique est
relativement uniforme
il est à peu près le même partout dirigé
suivant lax d'enroulement du fil
si on lance un électron et un breton les
deux particules vont former des
trajectoires circulaire à cause du champ
magnétique mais dans des sens opposés
car l'électron est négatif alors que le
proton est positif et avec des
amplitudes différente car l'électron est
moins massif que le proton mais en
général la plupart des aimants ne
nécessite pas de courant électrique pour
fonctionner certains aimants possède
naturellement un champ magnétique
c'est ce qu'on appelle des aimants
permanents pour comprendre les
particules élémentaires comme l'électron
possède une propriété importante en
physique quantique qu'on appelle le spin
même si ce n'est pas la réalité
on peut en quelque sorte interpréter le
spin comme une rotation de la partie
culturelle même en tournant sur
elle-même
la particule engendre une sorte de
courant électrique qui comme dans le cas
de la bobine va générer un champ
magnétique
les particules élémentaires se comporte
ainsi comme de tout petits aimants et en
les regroupant de façon alignés on peut
ainsi créer des matériaux aimanté enfin
pour conclure les champs électriques et
magnétiques étant indissociables l'un
étant à la base de l'autre il est
naturel de les unifier en une seule
notion le champ électromagnétique ce
champ électromagnétique se comportent et
évolué d'une façon bien déterminer qu'on
peut résumer en quatre principes
fondamentaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle techniquement les
quatre équations de maxwell
la première équation nous dit qu'une
charge agit comme une source pour le
champ électrique
la deuxième équation nous dit qu à l
inverse il ne peut pas exister de
charges magnétiques
c'est à dire des objets qui ne
posséderaient qu'un pôle nord sans pôle
sud
ou vice versa un pôle nord magnétique
vient toujours nécessairement avec un
pôle sud
et si on essaye de couper un aimant en
deux pour séparer ses deux pôles on se
retrouve forcément avec de nouveaux
aimant plus petits les deux dernières
équation traduisent la façon dont
évoluent les champs électriques et
magnétiques l'un par rapport à l'autre
la première de ces deux équations nous
dit qu'une variation de champs
magnétiques va perturber le champ
électrique
si l'on déplace un aimant à l'intérieur
d'une bobine de fil on fait varier le
champ magnétique ce qui perturbe le
champ électrique et va mettre en
mouvement les électrons de cette façon
en secouant un aimant à l'intérieur
d'une bobine
on peut générer un courant électrique on
parle d'induction car une variation de
champ magnétique peut induire un courant
électrique dans un fil
cette technique est largement utilisé
par les éoliennes les centrales
nucléaires ou encore dans les téléphones
pour convertir du mouvement en un signal
électrique
enfin la quatrième équation nous dit
qu'un courant électrique ou plus
généralement une variation de champ
électrique entraîne elle même une
perturbation du champ magnétique
cette dernière équation est cruciale car
elle remet boucle avec l'équation
précédente
en effet faire varier un champ
électrique perturbe le champ magnétique
mais cette perturbation de champs
magnétiques va à son tour perturbé le
champ électrique
cette alternance entre champs
électriques et magnétiques permettent à
l'énergie électromagnétique de se
propager dans l'espace sous la forme
d'une onde qui se déplace à la vitesse
des photons virtuel c'est ce qu'on
appelle une onde électromagnétique dont
font partie les micro ondes les rayons x
les infrarouges ou encore la lumière
pour finir un grand nombre d'expériences
intéressantes sont expliqués par les
lois de l'électromagnétisme on peut même
en quelque sorte ralentir la gravité
pour ce faire il suffit de lâcher un
aimant au dessus d'une bobine de fil au
départ léman tombe de plus en plus vite
car il subit l'attraction de la terre
mais en se rapprochant de la bobine son
mouvement fait varier le champ
magnétique au niveau du fil
cette variation de champs magnétiques va
mettre en mouvement les électrons à
l'intérieur du fil la chute de l'aimant
génère ainsi un courant électrique dans
la bobine
mais comme on l'a vu précédemment une
bobine parcouru d'un courant électrique
génère elle aussi un champ magnétique
un peu comme un aimant ce nouveau champ
magnétique va venir s'opposer légèrement
au mouvement de l'aimant qui tombe et
ainsi ralentir sa chute à l'intérieur de
la bobine léman tombe plus lentement
[Musique]
m
oh